what do hurricane winds and your weight
have in common in this video we'll find
out
thanks to brilliant dork for sponsoring
this video if you've taken physics to
high school level you'll know there is a
difference between mass and weight mass
is measured in kilos or pounds if you're
from the 19th century while weight is
measured in Newtons
now we confuse those two all the time
because in everyday speech when we ask a
question like how much do you weigh we
often give an answer like how bloody
dare you instead of something like 800
Newtons we do this because a person's
weight and a person's mass are in the
same direct proportion everywhere on
earth weight is a force which means to
calculate it we can use Newton's second
law F equals MA where the force your
weight equals your mass in kilos
multiplied by the force of the Earth's
gravity which isn't actually a force
it's an acceleration man we are really
about according things by the right name
in case that's confusing think about it
like this if you were to jump out of a
plane and ignore air resistance then you
would start accelerating and falling
faster and faster at the rate of the
Earth's gravity which if you're an
engineer is ten meters per second
squared so after one second you'd be
falling at ten meters per second after
two seconds you'd be falling at 20
meters per second and so on that means
that to calculate the person's weight we
can just multiply their mass in kilos by
ten meters per second squared
the acceleration due to gravity to get
their weight so if you have a mass of 80
kilos that means you have a weight of
800 Newtons
but if the acceleration due to gravity
is the same everywhere it just makes
sense to keep the numbers small to talk
about kilos instead of Newtons
fortunately however not all of us are
engineers some of us are physicists
that's worse that means we know that the
acceleration due to the earth gravity
isn't actually 10 meters per second
squared it's closer to 9.81 but also
that it isn't the same everywhere in
fact the closer you get to the equator
the Earth's gravity gets weaker so even
though you would have a constant mass as
you get closer to the equator your
weight would decrease because the
acceleration that's acting on
has decreased this happens because the
earth isn't stationary it's spinning on
its axis and just like the circular
motion of a merry-go-round the rotation
of the earth provides a centrifugal
acceleration which increases the further
out from the axis of rotation
you are the acceleration is given by the
formula V squared over R where V is the
velocity and R is the radius of motion
it acts to try and fling you off the
earth but because the earth isn't
spinning very quickly it's not a very
big acceleration if you near the Earth's
poles then you're not far from the axis
of rotation which means that you don't
experience much of this centrifugal
effect well if you're near the equator
you experience a lot of it and because
this acceleration acts outwards away
from the earth while the force of
gravity acts inwards towards the earth
that means your mass is acted on by a
net smaller acceleration and so you
weigh less how much less well Earth's
surface gravity at sea level will varies
around nine point seven eight to around
nine point eight three meters per second
squared it also varies a bit without a
tooth so we're talking a variation of
about half a percent and that has
actually been compounded by the fact
that the Earth's rotation causes it to
bulge at the equator the Earth's not a
sphere is technically an oblate spheroid
what that means is that at the equator
there's a greater distance between you
and the Earth's center of mass then
there is at the poles and so because
gravity is acting over a greater
distance it means that the gravitational
acceleration is a weaker but it gets
stranger still because as well as
weighing less the closer you get to the
equator you weigh less the faster you
travel east this was discovered at the
turn of the 20th century when a series
of research ships from the Institute of
geodesy in Potsdam which I can only
assume is one hell of a party school
work performing experiments across the
world's oceans on the strength the
Earth's gravity back home analyzing
their data was a Hungarian physicist
named Baron Rowland on eat fish and he
noticed that as well as the Earth's
gravity being weaker the closer that the
ships got the equator but gravity
measured was weaker when they were
traveling east and stronger when they
were traveling west consistently across
all their measurements you can actually
see this really clearly in this one
graph from a repeat experiment in 1908
originally the science ship is moving
slowly westward then quickly westward
then reverses direction and moves slowly
eastward over all the ship experiences a
change in gravity of around a hundredth
of a percent its Bush cleverly
identified that this effect was also
because of the Earth's rotation but in a
more subtle way when we're thinking
about motion on the Earth's surface such
as how gravity works we have to remember
that our coordinates are fixed relative
to the Earth's surface so latitude
longitude height but that the earth is
also rotating what that means is that
we're working in a non inertial
reference frame and it's called that
because we are experiencing on the
surface and acceleration when seen in a
reference frame that's exterior to the
earth such as the reference frame of the
solar system what that means is that we
have to make some corrections to the
equations of motion that we use to for
example calculate local gravity what I
want to do is take you through this
derivation because it's really quite
simple but I think really quite cool and
at the end of it there's a connection
between two bits of physics that you
wouldn't expect let's say that you're on
the surface of the earth and have some
north-south velocity lowercase V and an
east-west velocity u that would mean
that you're engaging in circular motion
around two different axes your
north-south velocity V is effectively
moving you in a circle with a radius the
same as the Earth's which we can call
our your east-west velocity U however is
taking you in a circle whose radius
depends on your latitude it's radius is
R times the cosine of your latitude when
you're at the equator latitude zero its
radius is going to be R while if you're
at the pole latitude 90 its radius is
zero that means then that by moving
along these two circles you're also
creating some new centrifugal
acceleration
radially outwards in the case of your
north-south velocity and along the
east-west axis but still outwards in the
case of your east-west velocity except
your velocity in the east-west direction
isn't only your own because remember the
plier is rotating so while your
centrifugal acceleration radially
outwards is given by the normal formula
that's V squared over R your centrifugal
acceleration in the east-west plane is
given by a more complicated formula
it's your total the velocity squared
over the radius of motion so that means
you plus the velocity you have because
of the planets rotation all squared
divided by R times the cosine of
latitude well write U sub P for the
planetary velocity for now remember
though we're interested in the extra
centrifugal acceleration that you
experience because you're moving so we
need to subtract the centrifugal
acceleration that a stationary object
would experience anyway just from the
rotation of the earth but that's easy to
do we can use the same formula and just
set the local velocity U to zero
expanding out this bracket then two of
these terms cancel so we're left with
just the one square term and this cross
term so these are the two extra
centrifugal acceleration you create by
moving around on the surface of the
rotating earth but we're interested in
the effect this has on your weight which
means the effect that they have on the
acceleration you experience radially as
that's the direction gravity acts in
towards the center of the earth to
calculate this is a simple bit of
geometry we already have one component
of acceleration acting radially V
squared over R and one which is inclined
at an angle to it a little bit of
trigonometry shows that this angle is
none other than your latitude and so the
final change in gravity experienced
because of your velocity is given by
this formula where we've multiplied the
second acceleration by the cosine of
latitude we can make this look a lot
nicer by substituting in the equation
for u sub P which comes from circular
motion around your latitude and writing
your total velocity as
calculated by Pythagoras as capital V
we're left with this nifty little
expression which has two components the
second component is basically the
centrifugal acceleration you need to
create in order to remain on the Earth's
curved surface well the first term is
more interesting the first term is
effectively the Coriolis effect just as
poleward motion is horizontally
deflected by the earth's rotation
east-west motion is vertically deflected
so your local gravity is deflected in
much the same way that the winds that
form a hurricane are and compare this
expression to the Coriolis parameter
which we use in meteorology for that
purpose though not by as much if you
were to travel due east at 20 meters per
second which is 72 km/h 15 or which is
London then you would experience a
decrease in local gravity of naught
point naught naught to 9 meters per
second squared or equivalently if you
have a mass of 80 kilos you would weigh
naught point to 3 Newton's less which is
still really cool so perhaps the
takeaway from this is that if you want
to lose weight then people are right to
advise that you go running just to
maximize your results make sure your
head east fast if you enjoyed the
derivation in this video then you almost
certainly liked learning about cool bits
of maths and physics through worked
examples and if that's you then ho boy
do I have an announcement for you
introducing brilliant dog that's right
it's a whole website of maths and
science problems they're interactive
they're beautifully illustrated they're
expertly written I can't keep up that
intensity the derivation we did in this
video involved both gravitational
physics and also rotating reference
frames in classical mechanics and when
you know it brilliant has expertly
written modules on both of these topics
so if you'd like to explore more about
how the earth rotating causes some
unusual physics then you can learn
through solving problems and testing
yourself it's honestly the single best
way to learn having said that I've long
wanted to brush up
my iron oxide II chemistry so I will be
checking out their new chemistry course
if you'd like to join me then held on
over to Berlinda org slash Simon Clark
and the first 200 subscribers to do so
will get 20% off their premium annual
subscription or if you want you could
buy a subscription for a friend or a
loved one perhaps even an engineer so
they could learn some proper science
thank you for watching this video I made
it because of a chance discovery I made
on reddit so that took me down a neat
little rabbit hole of planetary dynamics
which I hope you found interesting too
if you did find it interesting if you
learn something then pop it alike give
it a share to people you might find
interesting and you can always subscribe
to this channel if you want to see more
of this kind of thing I guess that just
leaves me to say thank you again for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one